-Hey, YouTube.
Here now with an original,
never-before-seen performance
of "Butter," the number-1 song
on the Billboard Hot 100 chart
for the last seven weeks,
it's BTS!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Smooth like butter ♪
♪ Like a criminal undercover ♪
♪ Gonna pop like Trouble ♪
♪ Breakin' into
your heart like that ♪
-♪ Cool shade stunner ♪
♪ Yeah, owe it all
to my mother ♪
♪ Hot like summer ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm makin' you
sweat like that ♪
-Break it down!
-♪ Ooh, when I look
in the mirror ♪
♪ I'll melt your heart
into two ♪
♪ I got that
superstar glow, so ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Do the boogie like ♪
-♪ Sidestep right-left
to my beat ♪
♪ High like the moon,
rock with me, baby ♪
-♪ Know that I got that heat ♪
♪ Let me show you,
'cause talk is cheap ♪
-♪ Sidestep right-left
to my beat ♪
♪ Get it, let it roll ♪
-♪ Smooth like butter ♪
-Hey!
-♪ Pull you in like no other ♪
-Turn it up.
-♪ Don't need no Usher ♪
-♪ To remind me you got it bad ♪
-♪ Ain't no other ♪
♪ That can sweep you up
like a robber ♪
-Uh-huh.
-♪ Straight up, I ♪
-♪ Got ya ♪
-♪ Makin' you fall like that ♪
-Break it down!
-♪ Oh, when I look
in the mirror ♪
♪ I'll melt your heart
into two ♪
♪ I got that
superstar glow, so ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Do the boogie like ♪
-♪ Sidestep right-left
to my beat ♪
♪ High like the moon,
rock with me, baby ♪
-♪ Know that I got that heat ♪
♪ Let me show you,
'cause talk is cheap ♪
-♪ Sidestep right-left
to my beat ♪
♪ Get it, let it roll ♪
♪♪
-♪ Ice on my wrist,
I'm the nice guy ♪
-♪ Got the right body
and the right mind ♪
♪ Rollin' up to party,
got the right vibe ♪
♪ Smooth like ♪
-♪ Butter ♪
-♪ Hate us ♪
-♪ Love us ♪
-♪ Fresh boy pull up,
and we lay low ♪
♪ All the playas get movin'
when the bass low ♪
♪ Got Army right behind us
when we say so ♪
-♪ Let's go ♪
-♪ Sidestep right-left
to my beat ♪
-♪ Right-left to my beat ♪
-♪ High like the moon,
rock with me, baby ♪
-♪ Know that I got that heat ♪
♪ Let me show you,
'cause talk is cheap ♪
-♪ Sidestep right-left
to my beat ♪
♪ Get it, let it roll ♪
-J-Hope, let's go!
-♪ Smooth like ♪
-♪ Butter ♪
-♪ Cool shade ♪
-♪ Stunner ♪
-♪ And you know we don't stop ♪
-♪ Hot like ♪
-♪ Summer ♪
-♪ Ain't no ♪
-♪ Bummer ♪
-♪ You be like, "Oh, my God" ♪
-♪ We gonna make you
rock and you say ♪
-Hey!
-♪ We gonna make you
bounce, and you say ♪
-Hey!
-♪ Hotter ♪
-♪ Sweeter ♪
-♪ Cooler ♪
-♪ Butter ♪
-♪ Get it, let it roll ♪